[Musique]
merci Isabelle foren de nous accompagner
pendant cette première demi-heure vous
êtes élu des haut C membbres du groupe
Union centriste porte-parole du MoDem on
va revenir sur l'actualité avec vous et
on commence d'abord par cette recrue
d'essens des actes antisémites Gérald
armanin a donné le chiffre de plus de
1700 actes antisémites recensés dans le
pays depuis le 7 octobre quelle réponse
politique on apporte après la marche de
dimanche est-ce que pour vous elle a un
sursaut durable il faut en tout cas ce
qui est dramatique c'est l'importation
du conflit de toute façon dans notre
pays donc il y a tout un arsenal
juridique en dehors de la réponse
politique il y a déjà un arsenal
juridique qui existe j'ai travaillé
d'ailleurs en 2022 sur un rapport sur
les actes antireligieux qui a été remis
à Jean Castex à l'époque où on pointait
déjà ce problème du conflit et de
l'importation du conflit et on voyait
effectivement malheureusement les
recrudescens d'actes antisémite quand il
y avait un conflit Isra en Israël
notamment comme c'est le cas
actuellement le é clair voilà c'est
c'est c'est c'était pointé alors nous ce
qu'on a vu dans notre rapport et qui
existe actuellement est ce que fait le
ministère de l'Intérieur et maintenant
faut que ça suive avec le ministère de
la justice c'est l'arsenal juridique qui
existe les plaintes déjà le signalement
qui doivent être fait et ça c'est
important et ensuite la réponse qui
doivent être apporté le suivi des
victimes et également alors il y a il y
a tout un arsenal juridique qui est
renforcé en plus quand il y a une
atteinte
occulte mais il faut effectivement
toujours mieux protéger les victimes
c'est ce que fait he le ministère de
l'Intérieur actuellement puisque il y a
quand même énormément d'enquêtes en
cours et il y a déjà plus d'une
trentaine de condamnations mais est-ce
que ce que vous avez vu aussi dans ce
rapport c'est pas la la difficulté pour
les victimes de porter plainte les
hésitations qu'elles ont à le faire tout
à fait tout à fait et c'est ça l'objet
essentiel de ce rapport c'est de
sensibiliser et les responsables de
culte et euh d'autre part les victimes à
aller faire cette démarche pour toute
pour tout problème et pour toute
atteinte notamment aux personnes il faut
encourager ces démarches parce que plus
on a connaissance des faits mieux on
peut y répondre c'était vraiment le le
souhait et puis également dans ce
rapport on a encouragé euh les
préfectures notamment euh également la
justice dans les territoires à se mettre
en rapport avec les cultes dans chaque
région pour mieux communiquer et pour
faire connaître également les mesures de
protection qui existaient en France elle
est suffisamment rendez-vous la justice
quand il y a des plaintes de ce type
écoutez la justice on lui a rapporté on
lui a apporté depuis 6 ans des moyens
énormes supplémentaires moi j'étais hier
encore à la cour d'appel de
Dijon on part de loin on part de loin
dans le rattrapage des des moyens donc
bah ils nous disent que il faudrait
toujours en faire plus on fait plus pour
répondre mais pour ça il faut
effectivement les personnels il faut
résorber tout le stock des affaires qui
n'ont pas été traitées ou qui ne sont
mal traité donc là il y a il y a
toujours besoin d'être encore plus à
l'écoute on développe énormément de
moyens il faut les faire connaître aussi
il faut les faire connaître auprès des
des victimes l'autre sujet ce sont ces
rencontres de Saint- acte 2 Emmanuel
Macron qui reçoit aujourd'hui les chefs
de parti il y aura des absents Olivier
fort le socialiste l'insoumis manuel
bpard et erriic cioti pour les
républicains qui explique entre autres
son absence par l'absence d'Emmanuel
Macron dimanche à la marche contre
l'antisémitisme c'est regrettable pour
vous l'absence moi je dis que les
absents ont toujours tort et quand un
président de la République surtout en
dans cette période de difficulté que
nous vivons de crise internationale et
et et européenne également
je pense c'est pour ça que tous les
autres quand même il vont c'est que
quand le chef de l'État vous propose un
échange est toujours bon d'aller
échanger après ce qui compte c'est aussi
de pouvoir avancer mais je crois que
mettre sur le même plan la présence à
une marche et la son absence pour Eric
cotti aujourd'hui ça n'a absolument rien
à voir c'est c'est pas très honnête
honnêtement enfin franchement c'est une
opportunité de discussion après cha est
libre d'y apporter ses réponses mais il
y a des sujets le chef de l'État ouvre
sa porte à des discussions
transpartisanes qui à mon avis sont
intéressantes quand même pour notre pays
on va parler des des sujets mais un mot
puisque Eric sotti répond ce matin à
Emmanuel Macron qui l' accusé de faute
politique he lors qu'il a annoncé son
absence et ce matin dans une lettre
ouverte sitif fusti je cite l'obsession
du palabre sans lendemain d'Emmanuel
Macron et il accuse le chef de l'État je
le cite là encore en démultipliant les
initiatives extérieures au champ
institutionnel de nourrir la crise de la
démocratie qu'en dites-vous je RIC Sotil
est dans son rôle d'opposant voilà
euh je pense que sur le sujet de la
démocratie et on en parlera on peut
faire il faut avancer il faut faire des
choses vous savez bien je suis membre du
MoDem et qu'on a un certain nombre de
propositions sur le sujet et que nous
sommes en attente donc que si c'est
l'occasion aujourd'hui encore d'en
parler il faut aller en parler et il
faut pas en parler que dans les médias
il faut aller en parler avec les
décideurs allez justement on va parler
du fond puisque parmi les points abordés
lors de ces rencontres de saintem la
question du référendum sujet qui sera
également abordé en séance la semaine
prochaine ici au Sénat puisque les
socialistes ont déposé un texte dans
leur niche on voit tout ça avec audre
[Musique]
vetaz bonjour Audrey bonjour bonjour et
Audrey la semaine prochaine à l'occasion
d'une de leur niches parlementaires les
socialistes présenteront ce sera le 22
novembre une proposition de loi pour
simplifier le référendum d'initiative
partagé oui l'objectif c'est de le
rendre réalisable car depuis qu'il a été
instauré en 2008 aucun Rif n'a pu être
organisé tellement les conditions de
mise en œuvre sont compliquées alors
Yann Chantrel sénateur socialiste des
Français de l'étranger c'est emparé du
sujet il propose plusieurs pistes pour
simplifier tout cela en commençant par
réduire le nombre de signature
nécessaire pour déclencher la procédure
pour l'instant il en faut 4,8 millions
soit 10 % du corps électoral il propose
de ramener tout ça à 1 Millionen la
proposition de loi propose aussi de
donner plus de pouvoir aux citoyens oui
faire en sorte que le référendum
d'initiative partagé soit plus partagé
justement pour l'instant l'initiative
vient des parlementaires elle pourrait
avec cette proposition venir des
citoyens charg à eux de récolter les
signatures une fois qu'ils les ont ils
vont voir les parlementaires pour
valider tout ça avec sans signature de
sénateurs et de députés et puis dernier
point les socialistes veulent étendre le
champ du référendum aux questions
fiscales pour l'instant le rip ne
concerne que l'organisation des pouvoirs
publics les réformes relatives à la
politique économique et sociale ou la
ratification d'un traité susceptible
d'influencer le fonctionnement des
institutions alors cette proposition de
loi elle vient de connaître une mauvaise
passe oui elle a été rejetée par la
commission des Lois du Sénat vous nous
expliquerez tout ça motif invoqué par le
rapporteur Philippe Bas les solutions
que cette proposition envisage sont pour
certaines inabouties ou contestables
dans leur principes même s'il soulligne
que l'initiative contribue utilement aux
réflexions sur le sujet il rappelle que
le chantier vous en avez parlé a déjà
été amorcé par le Président de la
République et les présidents des deux
assemblées lors des précédentes
rencontres de Saint-Denis pas question
donc de faire doublon mais les
socialistes ça vous pas vaincu non il y
a encore les discussions en séance le 22
novembre et puis le vote et ils ont une
carte à jouer en essayant de mobiliser
la majorité présidentielle la c'est il
vous ils ont fait appel à vous pardon
Emmanuel Macron lui-même s'est
positionné en faveur d'une
simplification du Rip c'était en octobre
dernier devant le Conseil
constitutionnel écoutez cette procédure
utile est aujourd'hui excessivement
contrainte sa mise en œuvre doit être
plus simple et les seuils permettant son
usage comme peut-être ses procédures
devraient dèslors être revu le président
est notamment d'accord pour abaisser le
nombre de signatures à 100 million et
pour élargir le champ d'application du
Rip aux questions de société même s'il
insiste sur le fait que selon lui le rip
ne doit pas avoir pour effet d'abroger
une loi promulguée depuis moins de 5 ans
ni de porter sur le même objet qu'un
texte en cours d'examen au Parlement ou
pas encore promulgué alors question
est-ce que vous allez voter pour cette
proposition de loi le 22 novembre je
suis la commission des lois et on a
rejeté le texte la proposition
socialiste pour les raisons qu'a invoqué
Philippa le rapporteur sur le fait que
c'était éit inabouti et que c'était un
peu compliqué dans la dans la mise en
œuvre en tout cas je suis d'accord il
faut à mon avis travailler sérieusement
ce sujet on avait pensé en tout cas à
l'époque j'étais député travailler sur
cette question en 2018 lors de la
proposition de travail sur la réforme
des institutions effectivement toujours
pour ces raisons d'abaissement du seuil
alors là il il propose un million nous
on était pas sur ces chiffres je sais
plus exact si on était pas sur 1 et demi
2 million enfin en tout cas l'idée est
intéressante moi je crois quand même que
c'est un sujet qui doit être travaillé
de façon un peu plus entre guillemets
par une par une par un vrai projet de
loi de réforme institutionnelle
peut-être plus large que uniquement sur
le référendum d'initiative populaire il
faut il faut en tout cas sur ces
questions je pense il y a il y a un vrai
sujet de de dé démocratie il y a un vrai
sujet là-dessus les socialistes ont
raison mais on le partage nous aussi
avec la majorité présidentielle c'est
qu'il y a une appétence en tout cas il y
a une demande des citoyens de mieux
participer à la vie publique alors ça
passe par un référendum et peut-être
effectivement assouplir les les
conditions en tout cas c'est ce qu'a dit
le rapporteur également he il a il a
bien pointter que c'était un sujet mais
sur lequel il faudrait prendre un peu de
temps on en a pris hein c'est c'est
clair on on a presque trop pris mais ça
fait partie des sujets que nous au modem
on porte depuis longtemps ce souhait
d'avancer sur ces questions de
démocratie sur ces questions de parole
des citoyens mais dans un équilibre si
vous voulez parlementaire et citoyenneté
participation citoyenne mais on a fait
déjà pas mal de choses avec notamment la
convention citoyenne et les deux
conventions citooyennes qui ont permis
cette expression ça veut dire quoi
inabouti et contestable c'était quoi les
points qui coinçaient dans dans la je
pense que la mise en œuvre était nous
sembléit effectivement euh pas pas très
réaliste à ce stade
l'élargissement des
sujets on peut pas le voter comme ça ce
à ce stade moi je suis pas d'accord sur
cet
élargissement sur les sujets fiscaux non
je crois qu'il y a un moment il faut se
mettre autour d'une table peut-être
réfléchir on avait eu l'idée le
président de la République dans son
dernier projet projet présidentiel avait
l'idée de réunir un certain nombre de
personnes pour réfléchir sur la réforme
des institutions et moi-même je fais
partie avec un certain nombre de de
d'amis parlementaires de de du défi
démocratique c'est c'est si vous voulez
avec V legendere on on on on souhaite
toujours aller plus loin malheureusement
pour le moment nos propositions c'est le
moins qu'on puisse dire sont pas
forcément ça elleaboutit pas et vous le
dites c'est depuis le premier qu
oui mais oui je le dis parce que je je
voterai pas pour autant une PPL de ce
type parce que c'est pas voilà c'est pas
un travail c'est un travail qui
nécessite un peu de temps mais il faut
s'y mettre maintenant est-ce que ça
permettrait pas d'envoyer un signal
justement non je pas envoyer le signal
c'est le débat pourquoi pas le débat il
participer donner notre avis c'est ce
qu'a fait le rapporteur et c'est pour ça
que moi j'étais tout à fait d'accord
avec la finalement la réponse mesurée
qu'il a faite alors pas d'élargissement
au sujets fiscaux le président de la
République propose un élargissement
notamment au thème de société est-ce que
vous êtes
favorable
je je je il a lancé cette
piste notamment ça ça permettrait de
mettre le débat migratoire et aussi le
débat sur la famille dedans il y a des
demandes sur ce sujet moi je sais pas si
la fin de vie enfin quand on interroge
les Français ils sont assez favorables à
des à des évolutions sur ce sujet euh le
débat migratoire je vous le dis
sincèrement au sein de la majorité
présidentielle vous le savez très bien
euh nous n'y sommes pas favorables et
pourtant Emmanuel Macron il ouvre le
champ du référendum pour que ce soit
possible je je pense
qu'il de mettre le sujet en débat avec
les partis politiques parce que c'est
les partis politiques qui sont chargés
aussi euh d'animer la vie politique et
la vie démocratique donc c'est un bon
débat à mettre après sur souz pas qu'il
aboutisse c'est ça ce débat vous ne
souhaitez pas qu'il aboutisse je ne sais
pas si euh il faut faire le référendum
c'est ça la question est-ce qu'il faut
le faire le référendum moi pour le
moment euh je suis réservée sur ce sujet
j'ai pas eu l'occasion on n'a pas eu
forcément l'occasion d'en débattre d'en
débattre encore au sein de nos instances
politiques respectives pour les
centristes mais euh comme d'ailleurs mes
amis et les partenaires de Renaissance
sont réservés sur ce sujet pour le
moment je crois qu'il y a une autre
façon de débattre de ces questions on
fait une loi notamment sur les questions
d'immigration on a une loi on aura un
débat cette loi prévoit et j'espère
qu'elle sera votée et qu'elle pourra
aboutir assez rapidement en CMP elle
prévoit notamment chaque année un débat
parlementaire je crois que c'est aussi
la question des parlementaires on va en
parler de la loi immigration mais sur le
référendum il y aura un débat au Sénat
le 12 décembre que les républicains vont
faire examiner le proposition de loi
constitutionnelle sur le sujet ça veut
dire que le groupe centriste s opposera
pour l'instant nous effectivement nous
sommes opposés donc ils auront pas la
majorité
répse on va répondre sur on sera
peut-être pas opposé à l'ensemble des
sujets qu'il souhait aborder il aura une
nuance c'est Philiipe bonc qui ser sera
chargé de de répondre on va y travailler
on a commencé à travailler sur le sujet
mais en tout cas euh nous sommes
effectivement réservés sur ce sujet vous
le savez ça veut dire que le sujet de
l'immigration fracture la la majorité
sénatoriale mais ça on l'a vu pendant le
débat même si vous avez trouvé un accord
est-ce qu' va aussi fracturer votre
majorité la majorité présidentielle lors
du débat à l'Assemblée je le souhaite
pas je le souhaite pas on a commencé
nous à travailler avec les députés
démocrate justement pour leur expliquer
l'accord que nous avions notamment
trouvé sur cet article 4 bis qui était à
notre initiative donner la main au
préfet sur cette circulaire de sur les
métiers en tension ça veut dire que le
groupe modem le votera le modem je le
souhaite je souhaite qu'il maintienne et
qu'il conserve l'article cabise après on
a fait évaloir les sujets sur lequels il
fallait évoluer la question de la me de
toute façon sera aussi exposée via un
rapport qui sera rendu début décembre
demandé par madame la Première ministre
donc si vous voulez sur tous ces sujets
il y a le temps de l'Assemblée nationale
il y a le temps de la discussion je
pense que nous nous sommes les
centristes capables de discuter
évidemment avec les députés qui sont à
la qui sont rapporteurs pour certains et
que moi je connais très bien qui sont
des gens mesurés qui savent faire un bon
travail parlementaire vous savez je je
suis pas sûr finalement que ça soit au
sein des sont triste et de la majorité
que les que les sujets soient le plus
difficile je pense que du côté des LR il
y a des questions qui se posent entre la
position des LR ici avec lequel on a pu
trouver un accord avec lequel on a pu
trouver un un un texte et aboutir sur un
texte et la position de certains d'entre
eux notamment du président du groupe qui
dit je veux détricoter le texte il
ferait bien quand même de discuter un
peu avec le président du groupe LR du
Sénat mais chez vous vous souhaitez que
en tout cas vos députés après on verra
le reste de la majorité présidentielle
vote cet article 4 bis sur les métiers
en tension mais reviennent quand même
sur laame en tout cas regarde ce qu'on a
voté nous on a expliqué ce qu'on avait
voté on a transformé laame on a réduit
le panier de soins
essentiellement je pense que le rapport
de Monsieur stéphanini monsieur Evin
permettra un éclairage supplémentaire en
tout cas il y a il y a une proposition
intéressante il faut quand même revoir à
mon avis le panier de soins après ame
Amu je pense moi je je vous dis les
députés j'ai été député j'ai été à la
commission des lois on regarde un texte
on l'étudie sûrement revoir la question
des allocations non contributives vous
savez des allocations versées parce
qu'on est passé de 6 mois en situation
régulière à 5 ans bon ça franchement
personnellement ça me convient pas il y
a d'autres sujets sur lequels on a fait
un très bon travail notamment les
protection pour permettre les expulsions
la levée des protections et là on l'a
fait valoir également euh le travail de
navette doit se faire moi ce que je
souhaite surtout c'est qu'on puisse
aboutir assez rapidement début 2024 à
une commission mixte paritaire
conclusive et c'est pour ça qu'il faut
d'ors et déjà se parler
s'écouter se respecter vous le dites
aussi à Sacha Houlier ça bien sûr
c'était pas sachou c'était pas
respectueux son interview dans le Figaro
en plein examen du texte au Sénat si
vous voulez les les assemblées elles
font un travail qu'on soit à l'Assemblée
nationale ouou au Sénat on se respecte
on respecte notre travail il faut savoir
qu'on a
d'éminents juristes aussi à la
commission des Lois du Sénat et que
c'est une belle commission qui a fait un
travail sérieux que nous avons à nous un
rapporteur centriste Philippe boncarer
je l'ai déjà citer qui a fait un travail
depuis le mois de février extrêmement
consciencieux avec Madame Jourda on peut
pas euh renier comme ça le travail d'une
assemblée il faut l'enrichir l'améliorer
garder cet équilibre aussi qui a été
trouvé et se garder euh des propos
caricaturaux est-ce que vous pensez
qu'une CMP conclusive peut peut avoir
lieu parce que tout le monde a tracé ses
lignes rouges dans les oui c'est normal
mais après c'est le jeu politique moi je
le souhaite parce que il y a une vraie
attente des Français sur ce sujet il y a
une attente de fermeté des Français euh
ils ont raison il y a des choses qu' ne
comprennent pas quand ce texte permet
notamment de réduire les délais de cours
euh devant les
différentes juridictions quand un
demandeur d'asile n'a pas le droit à
l'asile et ben écoutez il y a une
demande ça va dans le bon sens nous y
étions favorables il faut que sur chacun
des sujets les parlementaires soi
responsable parce qu'après si on n pas
de CMP conclusive ça nous amène très
très loin dans le temps et là l'attente
des Français sera déçu et on les
comprendra donc moi je dis travaillons
dors et déjà sur un certain nombre de
sujets ensemble pour pouvoir aboutir
j'espère au début de l'année 2024 voilà
c'est notre souhait en tout cas les
centristes je pense qu'on fait preuve de
modération et d'équilibre dans ce débat
merci Audrey mer à tout à l'heure oui on
parlera de la décriée Cour de Justice de
la République ça sera à suivre dans le
club d'abord on voit l'actualité dans
nos régions Isabelle Floren on va aller
à sens du côté d'osser retrouver Mathieu
Villerois de Galot bonjour merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous journaliste
liyonne républicaine et l'actualité
aujourd'hui dans Lyonne républicaine
c'est cette décision de la Commission
européenne de renouveler l'autorisation
du glyphosate pour 10 ans décision qui
fait pas l'unanimité Mathieu
oui bonjour Arian bonjour madame la
sénatrice effectivement nous avons fait
le choix de de revenir sur ce dossier
qui n'en finit pas de faire une une
polémique c'est vrai que c cet herbicide
controversé est le plus utilisé à ce
jour dans le monde et on voit bien que
tous les pays de l'Union européenne
n'arrivent pas à s'entendre sur
l'autorisation donc là ils ont fait le
choix de repartir pour 10 ans une
question toute simple madame la
sénatrice sur ces questionsl qui sont
des questions finalement qui touche à
tout ce qui est politique en faveur de
l'environnement pourquoi est-ce qu'on y
arrive pas on a l'impression que le je
dirais la majorité de l'opinion public
en France est plutôt favorable à tout ce
qui est environnement mais dès que ça
passe par la moulinette politique et ben
ça devient éminemment compliqué voire ça
bloque
pourquoi alors c'est des sujets qui sont
le ministre Marc F que je connais bien a
été très clair cette semaine finalement
au Sénat quand la position de la France
ça a été l'abstention il a expliqué
pourquoi il y a des sujets il y a des et
il y a des productions il y a sur lequel
on a pu avancer et c'est dommage de pas
avoir obtenu forcément des substitutions
à l'herbicide et puis il y a
malheureusement euh sur des cultures un
problème et il faut maintenir je
rappelle juste que la France et est
finalement beaucoup plus en avance qu'un
certain nombre de ces pays européens et
je rappelle également que le Luxembourg
qui avait interdit l'utilisation du
glyphosate est revenu sur la cette
interdiction parce que le problème c'est
d'avoir les produits de substitution
pour les agriculteurs donc moi je crois
que le ministre a une position
équilibrée il faut au maximum avancer en
recherche notamment pour trouver avec
les producteurs les euh produits
substitution c'est compliqué moi vous
savez euh sur la la question des
néonicotinoïdes je franchement j'ai j'ai
étais pas favorable j'étais député à
l'époque je m'étais expliqué avec lui et
j'avais une position parce que c'était
encore aussi un sujet de biodiversité
qui me touchait particulièrement mais là
sur le glyphosate ça fait 50 ans que les
les agriculteurs utilisent ce produit
c'est encore très compliqué de trouver
une solution de substitution euh les
scientifiques effectivement de part et
d'autre essaye d'avancer mais aussi
faisons les les choses dans l'ordre
ensemble avec l'ensemble des pays
européen moi ce que je constate c'est
qu'il y a très peu de pays pour le
moment il y en a même aucun en Europe
qui a trouvé toutes les solutions et
notamment les substitution donc on a je
pense eu la bonne démarche c'est-à-dire
de pousser quand on peut à utiliser
évidemment et et à supprimer le
glyphosate c'est déjà le cas sur les
espace public euh je rappelle que pour
juste remettre les choses à leur place
dans nos villes on nutilise plus depuis
longtemps C ces herbicides auprès de de
nos populations hein qui sont en contact
donc toiville c'est zéro glyphosate hein
en tout cas depuis un certain nombre
d'années mais effectivement pour
l'agriculture c'est encore une
utilisation évidemment très importante
et et souhaitée parce que il y a pas
cette substitution donc c'est un vrai
vrai enjeu
européen sur lequel il faut pousser
toujours mais mais la recherche
effectivement avance lentement parce que
ce produit évidemment est très plébisité
il faut je pense aussi faire une
information aux citoyens plus importante
ce qu'a fait d'ailleurs l'excellent
journaliste Patrick Cohen sur ce sujet
récemment merci
Mathieu merci à vousè bne journé la Une
de liyonne républicaine glyphosate
disons de plus c'est à la Une de votre
journal merci beaucoup Mathieu d'avoir
été avec nous merci Isabelle Floren
merci à vous d'avoir été notre invité
pendant cette première demi-heure